は　いや今回は、極めてしょうもないぞ
は　でも
は　少なからず気になってる人はいるパターン
は　逆になんだろう、みたいな
あ、わかった！
は　なに？
あぐぅっ
は　今日の企画はですね、
は　まあコンビニエンスストアというものが
は　あるわけじゃないですか
ま　はい
は　ものすごい数あるでしょ、最近
は　コンビニは
うんうん
パンツって
は　そう、パン
は　日常生活なら基本的になんでも、
は　足りるんじゃねえかくらい
は　いろんなものがあるんですけども、
は　まあ、逆に、
は　多すぎて、
は　ひょっとしたら、
は　不必要なものがあるんじゃないかっていう
一同　あー
は　逆の発想
は　だって…
一同　wwww
ま　うんうんw
は　そうそうそういうことそういうこと
は　その必要度がさぁ
は　わかんないわけじゃないですかわれわれ
は　そこにもう１人後輩がいるんですけども
は　４人で１人一品ずつ、
は　いるかいらないかだと、
は　いるんだよ全部、間違いなく
は　その中でも
は　コンビニで
は　１番これはいらないだろうという
は　優先度をつけた上で
は　１番いらないものを持ってきて
は　４人で協議した結果
は　コンビニでいらないもの第１位を決めようという
は　これを見て逆に
コンビニに、あ、こんなのも売ってんだっていう
ま　あー確かにね
は　役にたつかもしんないし、
wwwwwwwwwwwww
フィーリングでいく？
は　いや、結構真剣に考えてもらおうｔ
wwwwwwwww
大事、大事
は　結構その場に行かないとわかんないから
は　なぜこれが、いらないかという
うんうん
は　各々のもので
は　コンビニで
は　１番いらないと思われそうなものを
は　準備したので、ちょっと
は　まあ、理由と一緒に説明していただきましょう
は　まずは後輩さんからいきましょう
一同　え、何？何これ？？
は　あった？こんなの
後輩　あったあった
は　え、何これ？
後輩　靴磨きっすね！
はっはっwwwwwww
後輩　これはいらないでしょう！
後輩　コンビニで
は　うん、まあ確かにねぇ
は　例えば、
は　立ちションしてさ、靴にかかったら
後輩　これ？
は　そうそ．．．
ははっwwww
後輩　いらないと思ったっス
は　あー確かに
後輩　これすごいっス
は　よくやったw
後輩　これはすごいっスよマジ
は　なるほどなるほど
これは買ったのはぁ
多分ちっちゃい時から
うん．．．
って思ってたんじゃないだろうか
っていうものを
買ってきました
は　なるほどなるほど
それがこちらです
一同　あひゃひゃｗｗｗｗｗｗ
は　ばかたれが(((ﾍﾟｼｯ
え、だってさみんな思わない？？コンビニってさ
まんがあるって思ってさこう
600円！絶対600円なんだよ！！しかも
600円でおいてあるんすよ
手に取ってこう熟読するっていう
ことでもないって言う